i'm not gonna let myself down i'm not
gonna let my family down i'm not gonna
let i just feel like this is really
a moment for me to shine for once i'm
doing this for myself which is
rare you know
done that before during a recent
appearance on good morning america
pamela anderson opened up about her
upcoming broadway debut where she will
take on the role of a roxy heart in a
revival production of the tony
award-winning musical chicago and at 54
years old the actress says she's ready
to make a major splash after first
appearing on the hit show baywatch over
30 years ago this is a real great
opportunity for me i'm just so blessed
and lucky and
i'm just jumping off the bridge into it
and doing everything i can and i'm
surprising myself singing and dancing
and you know the role is fantastic and
it feels a little parallel sometimes i'm
doing it i feel like this seems very
you know meant to be also meant to be
the physicality that comes with the role
pam tells gma that learning the
choreography was a total dream my whole
body needs to be engaged anyway so this
is kind of honestly keeping me out of
trouble
you know fantastic i mean i'm a huge bob
fosse fan gwen verdon
and ranking it's just unbelievable that
i can that anyone even offered me this
kind of role so i'm gonna give it all i
have fans can see anderson on broadway
during the production's eight week run
kicking off on april 12.